there are manifestations that I consider
a very regrettable of sort of tribalist
thinking in religious groups in
political groups there was a great deal
of overlap in these categories of course
and and increasingly in the way that
people identify themselves
socioeconomically and then of course
there's always the old problem of race
which is you know it has been
capitalized on recently in very very
regrettable ways I think that tribalism
is the presumptive in effect contempt
for people that you identify yourself in
contrast to you know I'm listen with
amazement to people talking about
liberal professors in big secular
universities you know and I'm only broke
very big secular university and I can
promise I have never tried to
indoctrinate anyone I have no intention
of to overthrow the United States of
America you know but you hear these
incredibly aggressive and hostile
characterizations made of people as
groups and that's a very very very
dangerous thing to do I think one of the
things that's very nice about this
country historically and then you know
it's perhaps more Western than
northeastern is that people identify by
affinity that rather than by an received
identity you know the idea that you know
I'm from a certain region therefore I
have to believe in a certain politics
and I have to follow a certain religion
and all this sort of thing or no
religion depending that that takes
individual preference and choice and
affinity out of you know out of
individual experience and behavior and I
think that's a huge impoverishment of
people that they feel that they have to
fall into these loyalties rather than
looking around the landscape and seeing
where they can add something
you know see the find where people are
doing something interesting that
interests them also and it's you know I
I think that people can go here very
very well around and much more happily
around affinity than then around these
you know hard identifications that you
receive passively